[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on avale à jean lefer verbalisé parce
que j'avais un tract dans la poche ce
qui est quand même hallucinant il allait
me laisser partir mais je n'ai pas plié
correctement le trad c'est cool quand
même si je l'avais payé leur a même
fallu donc d'un côté ou leroy et de
l'hôtel des invalides pour la voir dans
la poche
il tourne super on ces gens là y'a rien
à dire
s'il reste vous demander de nous arrêter
pour prendre nos identités savoir si on
pouvait passer dans la rue revenu nous
voir en nous disant que j'étais en salle
participé à une manifestation dans la
rue et que je devais un trophée d'une
amende de 135 euros parce que je partais
un autocollant ici avec mon idée comme
ça
[Musique]